morning albert thank you so much for
being with us
we have quite a few very serious things
to talk about this morning but first i
just want to resolve one thing go to the
expert
you are born and raised in greece
how do you pronounce this new variant
big question on the front page of wsj um
the journal this morning omicron omicron
okay but you can't find a better way of
saying it okay
it's resolved that's it we've got it
okay but let's get down to business can
you give us the latest intel on
what you advise or understand about this
variant um how severe is the illness
that it can it can wreak
there are a few things that we know and
we are getting more and more information
but the three
the key three things that they are still
we haven't make let's say conclusions
but they are solid
are one is the clinical manifestation of
this virus
of this variant it means
it looks like transports faster looks
like it's milder but we don't know yet
we need to wait to see because there are
a lot of variants that are playing we
don't know if in south africa for
example people that they
seems to have a lot of this disease
they were having delta infections before
and also their younger people only five
percent of the population is more than
60. on the other hand a lot of them they
have hiv so you expect to see higher
percentages of
more severe disease so there are a lot
of unknowns that we need to
to but we will know unfortunately within
a few weeks because now we have
let's say cases in dozens in few weeks
we'll have in millions so i think we
will have a good understanding
let's say before the year end as to what
exactly it means for for clinical
manifestation so i think people very you
know the idea that it would be
spread faster by being potentially even
milder
that is being heralded as a possibly a
good thing that we could end up with
higher immunity natural immunity does
that make sense
no i don't think it is good
good news why we have reactions yeah i
don't think it's good news to have
something that spreads fast
spreads fast means that will be in
billions of people another mutation may
come you don't want that
but
it doesn't mean that we don't have let's
say the means to control it right now
and we need to wait to see how things
are evolved
so talking about the means to control it
i think you said that late november you
started working on a vaccine
on this tick that could target this
particular variant is that that's still
underway it is and um
i think that if there is a need for the
vaccine
we will have a vaccine in march
i don't know if there will be a need for
a vaccine
we'll know that in a few weeks
what we need to do to understand if
there is a need for a vaccine it is to
see if the current one
is providing an umbrella of protection
but it is solid enough which is
preferable which is way profitable of
course you don't want to go to a new one
for many reasons you don't want to go to
a new one not only because complicates
things
but you don't want to go to a new one
because the more you go away from the
original
the let's say the original the wild type
strain
the more
for several regions is not
good for the epidemiology of the virus
but nevertheless we don't know if we
need one
we will know in a few weeks
the conclusions
we can see it only holistically
the first data points that will come
will be in the lab
if the blood of people that have been
vaccinated with two doses or with three
doses and also we'll stay we will test a
better vaccine that we have and also a
delta vaccine but we have they don't
circulate
we have them yes and you will see how
effective it is in the lab
and the first test will come with
what we call a pseudo virus not as
accurate of a test but fast
the second wave after a couple of weeks
later of that will be with a real virus
this is very accurate
but also the final and
will come from countries that they have
good monitoring systems
either i suspect will be the first
country that will provide solid data
that
they will tell us real world efficacy if
the car and vaccinated people they have
a difference compared to the
unvaccinated people two doses compared
to three doses wayne of immunity et
cetera i want to come i want to come
back to israel but first in terms of
having this extra vaccine
how would it work like right now i think
your expectation is that
people you've said it would be like an
annual booster but if you need to put
this vaccine in place would would it be
like next year people would get two
shots
we don't know yet you don't know we
don't know yet it could be that um one
first of all i repeat it could be that
we don't need one right and we will know
the good news is that if we need one we
will have one
it isn't
and if we have one in march just to
answer i don't know if we will need just
one booster on what already we had or
you need to go from the beginning that
would be the worst case scenario but you
need to start the whole series again we
don't know that
okay so what about the the oral
medication that you are working on
that's a little bit i mean that i think
you have a
higher confidence that that would fight
any variant is that it's a different
kind of science
i have we have very very high
level of confidence that will fight this
variant and all
the ones that we have seen so far
the reasons are because
most of the mutations are happening in
the spike protein this is the reason why
vaccines that they are working on the
spike protein or treatments like
antibodies that they are working on the
spike protein we need to assess if it
still works or not
the oral medication that we have which
is a protest inhibitor doesn't work in
the spike works
by inhibiting a protease but it is vital
for this virus it's very difficult for
the virus to create
a strain that can live without this
protest
so that when we inhibit it
doesn't affect it
it's not impossible it's very difficult
but we know that those mutations they
don't affect that at all so we have very
very high level of confidence with the
current variant
the treatment that we have should work
at the same level i think it was
supposed to be
delivered by the end of this year and
what's realistic for regular people to
think that they could get that in their
pharmacy like what how far are we away
from that
place minus expectation will be not in
the old quantities but this year i think
we have submitted to fda our
applications fda is reviewing
um
fda would like to see the final
date also from our study there was a
surprise because of the mercs compound
that
the final the final numbers that created
the change um i don't expect in our case
that this will be the case and we will
have the data soon
so we will submit let's say
soon to fda
whether it's a matter of couple of weeks
but the whole thing and we have already
i think i posted even some in tweets
that the quantities from germany
in freiburg we are producing have been
shipped to the us
so we will have quantities in the us if
it is approved
uh
this month
so you'll have it and then what is the
timetable till it actually can be
starting to be prescribed by doctors and
no i think if it is approved and we have
it could be the next day we will not
have
millions this month
we will have thousands
we will have
hundreds of thousands in january
we will have millions
in the first quarter
10 million is the deal with the us
government 10 million years ago
government all the way
to the end of the year
the
total production that we are having
right now it is 80 million treatments
okay
we could scale it up if there is a need
even more
uh so we are waiting to see how those
things will will play so coming back to
you mentioned israel as the place where
you where has the data and you've called
it the place with the most reliable data
um what do you think that about the fact
that the united states isn't ranked up
there in your mind is
what have we not done right here in
terms of data
look i mean it's a little bit unfair
because here is a way bigger country
sometimes that creates way higher
complexities of course
but on the other hand also israel is not
an average 10 million people country
they know how to respond in crisis very
well because of the situation they are
living
they have electronic data
medical data records for almost everyone
99 of their population
and they they took it very seriously so
they continued
collecting information no matter if they
had controlled the disease so they were
the first ones to get vaccinations they
were the first ones to control really
the disease you remember in march
they were going out in the heim and
behind fighting i mean when we go back
in the history and look at this we'll
failure to
to handle data better in this country
hospitalization i wouldn't call it
failure but i think that
the complication of the
u.s healthcare system
and
maybe some decisions not to invest that
much in testing
could have been different decisions in
the beginning i think people realized is
that one of the things we'll look back
on and say had we gotten our testing
regimen better sooner
i think one of them was
sooner and then constantly so
when for example we started seeing the
waning of immunity
it was so clear in other countries and
we are having some gestations here
because we don't have the data to
demonstrate it here
it's not that was not happening we don't
have the data to demonstrate it and
that's you can't wait to have a lot of
bodies to demonstrate something you need
to be able to predict it with data and
act in periods of crisis before you have
that situation which is what others did
uk also was not that bad also they did
quite good job on this so in terms of
learning lessons one of the biggest
tragedies really from this incident is
the divide between the have and have not
countries in terms of vaccinations and
certainly people are not laying that on
the feed of pfizer but what do you feel
like the resource world your company and
broadly could have done better and
should be doing better
i think
i'll tell you what we did well and what
i think we could have done better okay
and what you did well was that we priced
it
at the levels that everybody could get
it the high-income countries they got
the price of let's say take away mill
but the middle-income countries they got
it at half of this price the low-income
countries they got it
at cost and we agreed with the us
government as a sponsor to buy a billion
dollars from us
at cost and give it completely free to
only the 92 so that's why i think we did
well
the second thing that i think we did
well was that we ramp up manufacturing
to a level that no one thought that we
could so that instead of trying to
resolve it with
a nor who gets
to resolve with an end everybody gets
so we ramped up this take that question
out of the equation take the question
who is getting
and
in the first half clearly higher income
countries were getting way more than the
lower income count the second half that
reversed
um now we have a situation
that a lot of
the countries
in africa for example
they asked us to stop sending anymore
because they can't because they can't
process it this is where i think we
could have done even us better
i could have asked
i could have foreseen it and asked
ourselves to partner earlier with ngos
on the ground to start running
educational campaigns
to start
trying to create infrastructure
we did things for example i'm sure you
have seen we have a project that we can
we are using drones
to transfer and drop
vaccine supplies in remote areas
we should have done it better
many other organizations should have
done it better on that i was very
pleased to see today that wh so
secretary tedder said that he appoints
someone
that
will focus exclusively on that creating
the infrastructure on the ground
for for for countries to be able to
create the
to to fight hesitancy and create
infrastructure to do it so i think
that's something that we could have done
also ourselves better fair enough okay
so we're here in washington and um
you you know you've been part of what
senator mcconnell called last night this
modern miracle modern medical miracle
how much good will
has this engendered for you on capitol
hill
i think has created tremendous will with
the
american people as a result tremendous
will with the capital here because that
goes very much uh in sync
but
i would think that easycom is a go
what countries how long did it cost
so i think
if we just think because we got it high
we can now relax that's very big mistake
we should continue earning
the trust of the average american and as
a result the support of the average
politician
every day spilled back better bill uh it
has some of the most significant
expansion of
drug um drug price regulation in decades
and you've called part of it price
fixing i mean do you are you okay with
where that landed um the house bill
in terms of the new price controls or or
you feel it's gone too far
no i i think it's gone too far there are
a few things that there i would
i'm really very happy to see in in this
bill and those are relaxation of the out
of pocket the problem with drug pricing
real problem that are crisis in in this
country in america it is
not the cost of drugs to the health care
system
this is 12
of the total cost so by definition
cannot be the big problem and actually
is going down the last few years
the big problem is the cost of drugs to
when you go to get them from the out of
pocket to the person not to the
individual and right now the way that
the system works it's almost like for
your drugs you don't have insurance you
pay everything from your pocket or the
vast majority although you have a very
good insurance the fact that in this
bill they are putting a cup on medicare
and actually are going to smooth it it's
very very very positive now
the fact that they are putting
provisions that it is they call it
negotiation it's price fixing it is that
the secretary of
health can say this is the price and if
you agree
it's fine if you don't agree you're
fine 96
yeah
nice negotiation right so it's not uh i
think that's only for like some
medicines that have been it is for some
medicines
exclusivity so so i i think it's wrong
but nevertheless uh my view is that i
prefer if we can have
something that
will i hate because of that
provision not to see the bill because i
think the provision of the out of pocket
for the american people it's a very very
big deal and it's a much needed reform
so i think we will continue working with
with congress
to try to to make sure that we have i
never advocated and i would not advocate
for
no reforms
i don't like status quo unacceptable i
think
we want changes we are just discussing
uh
the direction of some of these changes
so we'll work productively to see what
we can come with right so let's stay on
policy for a minute last night senator
mcconnell was
very articulate against vaccine mandates
saying it's just not the right time in
the economy
for businesses and at the same day that
mayor de blasio
put this down for
for private businesses vaccine mandate
where do you stand
i think there are two ways to see it one
is a political way and the other is a
public health
policy way
the political way unfortunately has been
politicized we all know it so it's a
political statement you wear a mask
likely you're a democrat you don't like
the republican right so
ridiculous
that's not about political affiliation
it's about health and best scientific
practices
i think that
it's a little bit controversial the
mandate because
some people they feel very active and
stronger
to them and they but also on the other
hand it works
and many countries now
are seen so big
i was for example speaking with
the greek prime minister the other days
and he told me that they put a mandate
actually they put
mandate if you don't get vaccinated and
you are above 60 years old 100 euros per
month 10.
it's a fine that's right delta airlines
and he told me i can't take it anymore
our hospitals are full
of the intensive care units we have to
postpone
electric surgery
so we need to push it now
as i said this country has different
culture
it's more free spirits not that the
greeks are not but uh right
yeah
but they have the same progress let's
ask the room so
vaccine mandates
yay or nay who's four of them here
okay
nays
we've got a couple maybe we'll hear from
you guys in the questions but in any
event it's pretty clear consensus here
yeah it is because they work i've seen
it even advisory where we had to make
a mandate for vascular people and
although we were at 90 but this 90 was
not moving and it moved to 97 percent up
to what 97
vaccinated so it's very big deal okay
we're going to go to questions in a
minute but um i want to talk a little
bit more about the scientific
breakthroughs and what they mean for the
future can you give us a sense of your
hopes for what the learning from mrna
will mean for cancer other infectious
diseases or rare diseases
yeah look mrna is very powerful
technology
i think we are scratching the surface
i think
we are having the first
demonstration of an effective
product with the vaccines
and that is with a modified rna
there are other programs that us and
many other companies are running for
other vaccines
there are other programs that many
companies are running for cancer years
now
and also there are other forms of rna
that they're even more advanced than
modifier rna which is the next
generation like self-amplifying rna
or let's say
circular a lot of these type of
technologies very revolutionary but just
to understand it's just one of the
revolutionary technologies is not going
to be the only one and will not work for
everything we have gene therapies we
have yeah there are in editing there are
so many things
that are happening and they are very
revolutionary right now the thing that
people need to understand it is that we
are entering a decade of a scientific
renaissance
it is not only the advancements in
biology
but it is the fact that advancements in
biology in synergy with
advancements in technology and
tremendous computational power they are
creating synergistic effects that were
unimaginable in the previous decade
so i think we will see significant
advancements because of that
and you've positioned your company to be
focused on
i think we're very well positioned as a
company as opposed to like generics or
consumer products at this point
i think science it is what would be the
name of the game everything is needed
right it's a consumer product needed
for pfizer we are focusing only on
science this is very clear
all forms of science
that can create breakthroughs that
change patients lives our purpose is
breakthroughs that change patients lives
that gives already magnitude
of the of the ambition so we are not
looking for incremental improvements
yeah breakthroughs that change patients
lives and that will come with science
i know it's nice to hear breakthroughs
with a positive connotation
um so let's let's see where are there
any questions here
here right here
we have a mic
thank you
baldas from bgd holding first let me
thank you for what pfizer has done
he's curious to get your thoughts
on the last point you made
about the synergy between biology
technology computing
in the context of
distributed innovation yours is a 100
year old company
partnered with the startup biontech
from the standpoint of bio ethics
i'd exp i'm curious to get your
thoughts
on that distributed innovation bioethics
yeah
it's an excellent question into 172
years company
founded in in new york and biotech is
way more younger company and the real
reasons why if the thing was so
successful was because we partnered like
equals
we didn't think we are goliath and they
are david and they didn't think this way
so we were equals and we just allocated
our resources i spoke about
technology powering
biology and the covet
development in our case and the
treatment
wouldn't be possible if we wouldn't put
substantial investments in digital
the years before the covet was able to
do the study very quickly
because we had digitized to very high
degree all our operations in clinical
development
and to go even more
it's inspirational the
the
from march of 2020 when we started the
treatment program the order until the
july of 2020
four months
we had synthesized and tested 600
different molecules
but eventually we selected the one that
we are now
seeing that happened because we
everything happened in
with computers
it was dramatic computational power that
we used and i think we have some of the
biggest computational powers in the
industry right now so now
the ethical
or let's say the bioethics
the time that this the science was
happening in small selected places is
over
it used to happen in the ivy leagues
or in five big pharmas the marriage
divisors of the world et cetera
it made sense at the time because
science was also so diverse at that time
for example cholesterol we knew is the
target when it comes to heart diseases
and statins one of the most prominent
ways to address it so it made sense for
fires or an elaborate to invest in
statins now for heart diseases we have a
zillion
of known
targets biological targets and for each
one of them zealand technologies can go
after them so placing singular bets will
never give anything we need to be part
of a biotech ecosystem
that needs to flourish in the country
and then you need to be able early to
partner with them as we did with
biontech and bring the scale
that is needed so those technologies can
come way faster where more effective
produce the scale et cetera
i don't know if i'm answering your
question
or but you can ask me on the court
okay we're all about time um but just
want to end with this uh we're at the
end of 2021
do you think we're ever going to get to
a day and if so what year do you think
it might be where
the the scourge of this disease is not
hanging over our every thought and plan
when when do you think we'll get back to
living where it's not the main things on
our mind weighing us down
i like the way you ask it because many
people are asking when coffee will not
exist i don't think we will see that
soon
but influenza
flu exists right still we live our lives
we don't live with that we flew in mind
every day i think we will reach that
level pretty soon
and i think there are so many the tools
that we have
developed so powerful vaccines so
powerful treatments
90 percent
effective in treatment that's
they are unheard things before so once
we get people vaccinate once we get
politics
out
of the equation
ones that have that's the small problem
that's why treatments unfortunately will
be needed because will never happen to
100 but we can live normal lives normal
lives means that you can go to
restaurants you don't need to wear masks
and
suffocate every every every day and and
all of that i think these things will
come and i think will come in a year
i think i don't think next year absent a
variant that changes everything i think
we were
in a good path mid of next year
to be having things under good control
that's hopeful thank you so much albert
laurel back to you thank you so much
thank you
you